Miss Réunion à 7 ans je crois que j'ai
bien noté 9 ans d'animer le Cervin Kaf
on en a parlé tout ça alors là dis-nous
ce que tu fais actuellement on va parler
encore de plein de choses mais notamment
ça une multitude de choses et notamment
un projet qui me tient vraiment à cœur
qui s'appelle la voix des femmes la voix
voie comme la voix la dessinée que nous
prenons toute malgré nous et tous et
toutes malgré nous et en effet c'est un
projet qui que je porte depuis
maintenant 5 ans et j'ai réussi à réunir
45 femmes toutes connues respectées dans
leur secteur d'activité donc ça va de
comédienne à des journalistes des chefs
d'entreprise des avocats des féministes
des danseuses des mamans de d'enfants en
situation de handicap j'ai vraiment
voulu aborder toutes les problématiques
de femmes parce que c'est un sujet qui
me tient réellement à cœur de
témoignages
et je tiens à le préciser ce ne sont que
des histoires vraies c'est à dire que
c'est 45 femmes qui ont témoigné là
c'est évidemment les comédiennes qui
font partie de la première session la
première tournée
toutes ces femmes m'ont fait confiance
et ont décidé de raconter pour la
première fois pour beaucoup d'entre
elles leur histoire leur vrai histoire
parce qu'il est vrai que au mouvement
Mitou très peu d'entre nous ont osé
témoigner pas du tout par l'acheter un
bien évidemment loin de là c'était plus
une forme de protection aussi avec
l'apparition des réseaux sociaux c'était
extrêmement compliqué et ce qui est
génial dans ce spectacle donc déjà je
tiens à le préciser tous les droits
d'auteur des textes vend des
associations qui œuvrent pour les femmes
ces femmes sont là pour les bonnes
raisons et en aucun cas pour se mettre
en avant parfait on peut l'applaudir
parce que ça c'est magnifique non mais
dis-moi d'abord cher Séverine nous on se
connaît depuis très longtemps on a fait
de très beaux voyages ensemble
d'ailleurs moi cette belle photo
m'a fait un des plus beaux cadeaux de ma
vie moi le dire il peut être très
généreux
moi je j'avais toujours rêvé d'aller en
pèlerinage à Jérusalem et à l'époque
Monsieur était ambassadeur d'un très
très grand goût groupe hôtelier on peut
le dire comme ça et c'est vrai que il
m'appelle Séverine je sais je sais que
tu as envie de partir tu m'en as
toujours parlé à Jérusalem et moi
j'étais enceinte de 6 mois vraiment
c'était le dernier moment où je pouvais
prendre l'avion et du coup je dis
Bernard j'y vais et en plus je vais y
aller avec maman parce que je sens qu'il
faut que je fasse ce voyage avec maman
quoi donc on y va je me bats quelque
part parce qu'en fait c'était que
Jérusalem et je dis Bernard je suis là
je ne peux pas faire autrement que
d'aller à Bethléem emmène-moi s'il te
plaît à Bethléem il réussit il se
débrouille on y arrive on était avec
Vanessa Demouy et Pascal et Mireille
voilà et c'était magique et c'est vrai
que quand je suis arrivée donc on est
parti à Bethléem et je voulais visiter
cette église cette fameuse église qu'on
qu'on nous a on nous a expliqué que
c'était une étape avec un âne un bœuf et
moi je m'attendais à voir ça il y a rien
de tout ça et quand le monsieur donc du
van nous dépose sur le l'esplanètes de
l'église il nous dit bon attendez-moi là
et là il y a un monsieur qui vient qui
le faite ensemble tu sais ce que c'est
et tout je sais pas ça va être un fils
et il me dit tu sais comment tu vas
l'appeler je dis oui je vais l'appeler
Joshua et là tu sais ce que ça veut dire
je sais pas non il me dit ça veut dire
lié au choix ça veut dire Jésus et là je
m'effondre d'ailleurs il m'appelait la
pleureuse
partout je pleurais je pleurais beaucoup
pleurer je dois dire tu as eu le
syndrome de Jérusalem pour toutes les
souviens je crois que le pire enfin le
plus beau et le pire moment donc dans
cette église il y a une pierre noire ou
est censée être
à la maison tous les deux
tailles au travers de cette émission te
remercier parce que ça a été un moment
magique de ma vie et voilà
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que ça te manque pas un peu
justement les feux de la rampe passer à
la télé comme avant parce que tu as
baigné la dent depuis ton enfance alors
écoute faire de la télévision est-ce que
ça manque ça commence à me titiller ah
depuis deux ans
ou tu aimerais participer oui j'ai des
idées
c'est le moment tu as la télé
j'aime bien que les projets soient
concrets et que voilà j'y travaille et
notamment sur un très très beau projet
donc
de nouveau au niveau télé alors oui
interview ou pas
franchement je crois vraiment avoir fait
le tour parce que fan 2 c'est quand même
duré 8 ans je crois non 9 saisons
plutôt d'interviewer des femmes qui sont
sous le feu des projecteurs toutes ces
femmes à la fois
d'être en lumière des femmes qui qui
font qui agissent mais qui ne sont pas
forcément sur le feu des projets
avec une célébrité quand même on aime ça
bonjour Britney je suis très contente
d'être ici je suis ravie de te
rencontrer je suis là en porte-parole de
ce que tu acceptes de dire toute la
vérité et rien que la vérité
toute la vérité bien sûr alors il y a
beaucoup de garçons t'imagines bien qui
sont amoureux de toi et qui se demandent
si tu as un petit ami en ce moment j'ai
rencontré pas mal de garçons plutôt
mignons mais je n'ai pas encore croisé
la personne vraiment spéciale alors j'ai
vraiment tout mon temps aimerait que tu
parles cette rumeur qui court en ce
moment entre toi et le prince William
je ne veux vraiment pas en parler cela
fait partie de ma vie privée mais je
pense qu'il est vraiment mignon
vous avez entendu comme elle a réussi à
glisser la question et le prince William
parce qu'en fait évidemment tu connais
tout ça la rédaction me dit il faut à
tout prix mais impossible de passer à
côté de cette question et moi j'étais
hyper gênée parce que je sais que je
n'aimerais pas qu'on me la pose
justement
[Applaudissements]
quelle autre personnalité tu as
interviewé parce que ça a duré longtemps
quand même j'ai eu cette grande chance
d'interviewer Jennifer Lopez Janet
Jackson Enrique
Iglesias lou bega
tu n'étais pas impressionné par les
stars c'est que quand moi je regarde
tout ça avec beaucoup de distance
maintenant fan 2 a fêté ses 25 ans il y
a un an maintenant et je regarde cette
gamine qui baragouine en fait j'ai
intervie Rihanna j'avais oublié
non non en fait on m'envoie une photo un
jour chez mais c'est qui
je m'en souvenais plus haut à l'époque
des Destiny's Child et c'est vrai que
quand je regarde cette gamine qui
baragouinait deux en anglais parce que
je ne parle pas très bien je suis pas
fluonne quoi je me débrouille mais et je
me dis elle est sacrément culottée je
pense que si on me demandait de faire ça
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui je serai
tétaniste je le ferais même pas avec
Sophie Coste vous avez une expérience
toutes les deux
qu'en fait c'est vrai j'ai commencé la
télévision grâce à Séverine moi j'étais
fan de Séverine je regardais fan 2 et en
fait j'étais à l'époque j'étais
étudiante en stylisme enfin bref et
on t'avait organisé un casting pas fan2
avait organisé un casting pour les
nouvelles trouver les nouvelles Spice
Girls à la française qui sont d'ailleurs
devenus les L5 en fait donc c'est ce fil
en blonde ouais c'est moi
et voilà et en fait j'ai commencé comme
ça grâce à fan de j'avais envoyé ma
vidéo vous chantez je dansais machin etc
pour faire partie du girlsbourg j'avais
besoin de de d'argent pour financer mes
études et en fait m'a dit le producteur
de fan 2 c'était le producteur de fan de
qui cherchait une fille pour animer une
nouvelle émission qui s'appelle des
clips et des bulles m'a dit bon toi tu
sais pas chanter tu sais pas danser tu
es nul mais
tchatche et tout est-ce que ça te dirait
voilà et j'avais 19 ans
j'arrive à M6
le Zénith quoi mais direct et du coup tu
te souviens tu as fait le on a fait le
Dance Machine et elle portait mon
costard bleu on s'appelle avec les
fringues
donc
c'est un petit monde le show business le
spectacle c'est un petit monde
parce qu'elle est vraiment
exceptionnelle cette jeune femme
Sophie fan d'elle et donc je ne loupe
jamais fan de le samedi et la première
fois que j'ai rencontré j'ai failli
chialer parce que pour la petite
histoire c'est vrai elle a failli être
assise ici à nos côtés parce qu'on avait
fait le pilote on avait fait l'émission
zéro avec toi et c'était avec moi et on
était côte à côte et apprendre avec
plein de selfies plein de trucs et c'est
dommage parce que ça aurait été un
bonheur de travailler avec toi
voyons on garde on garde nos âmes
d'enfants toujours c'est vrai tu vois on
garde nos âmes d'enfants tu vois on
rencontre quelqu'un qu'on a aimé quand
elle était plus jeune on est ému on est
très touché moi je suis ému quand je te
vois c'est vrai
[Rires]
et alors la comédie comédienne aussi
t'as fait plein de séries j'ai fait
plein de choses
du terme mais j'ai fait que la semaine
15 où j'étais le loup la petite sœur de
Vanessa Demouy avec qui nous étions
justement
j'ai également fait studio Sud qui était
diffusé sur M6 qui a révélé Diane Robert
et notamment Tomer Sisley et à vie
Marciano absolument et c'était une sorte
de Fame à la française
exactement et aussi dans Plus belle la
vie donc oui pas mal de longs-métrages
j'ai fait récemment long métrage qui
s'appelle la chose derrière la porte qui
est un long métrage fiction et c'était
génial je me suis éclaté donc avec des
FX enfin c'était des effets spéciaux
partout c'était génial et puis
évidemment le théâtre qui fait partie
intégrante de ma vie maintenant et là je
pars à partir de septembre sur tout sur
toutes les routes de France de Suisse et
de Belgique pour une pièce qui s'appelle
à quel prix tu m'aimes avec Marie-Hélène
Mancini et le beau Terence tel qui fait
ses premiers pas sur scène avec nous
encore une photo avec lui
vous a pas de photo avec lui donc vous
le connaissez
pas mal
tu me fais rire
si les choses devaient recommencer ce
serait la télévision bon tu continues le
théâtre évidemment on va reparler de la
voix des femmes bien sûr mais c'est la
télé tu as envie de faire quoi parce que
tu as laissé entendre des choses mais
concrètement tu aimerais faire quoi
diriger ta propre mission refaire des
interviews comme tu le sais faire ou
plutôt la comédie le théâtre tu veux
rester dans quel domaine en fait alors
alors d'aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque je faisais plein de choses on
me disait tu te disperses alors que moi
c'est mon mode de fonctionnement
étaient américains donc je ne comprenais
pas pourquoi me disait mais t'as pas le
droit de faire chier tu as pas le droit
de chanter tu as pas le droit de faire
l'Eurovision t'as pas le droit en fait
non je fais ce que je veux et tant qu'on
me propose et qu'on me donne
l'opportunité de le faire donc j'ai
réalisé plein de rêve comme ça et
aujourd'hui par contre si on me
demandait de choisir je ne choisirai que
le théâtre parce que je me sens bien sur
scène et en fait cette prise de risque
quotidienne et bien quelque part c'est
c'est jouissif quoi donc tu vois quand
on te regarde d'un coup ça me revient tu
as commencé extrêmement jeune on l'a dit
bon septembre il se réunion 9 ans la
première télé etc tu as traversé show
business qui fait si peur si on dit
était sorti indemne
de dire ça parce que on sait très bien
on sait très bien que c'est très
difficile c'est un métier difficile
c'est vrai je sais que tu as eu une
mauvaise expérience au début dans
l'émission de Sabatier ou le producteur
a piqué ton fric voilà oui qui passe à
bâtir
heureux alors voilà tu as traversé
des mouvements mytho d'ailleurs toi tu
l'évoque aussi dans ta pièce de femme ou
les femmes s'expriment librement et
c'est tant mieux ça va tu as pas eu de
d'histoire trop pénible moi je pense que
de toute façon
et moi c'est ce que je revendique il
faut pas mettre tout le monde dans le
même panier c'est à dire que moi j'ai
toujours été extrêmement bien entouré
j'ai mes parents qui ont tout supervisé
qui était jamais loin derrière moi et on
prenait toujours des décisions communes
ils n'ont jamais forcé à faire quoi que
ce soit etc mes parents que j'embrasse
et qui ont appris très vite que c'était
ma vocation et après j'ai envie de vous
dire on avance moi j'ai toujours pris ce
ce métier comme j'ai toujours habillé
l'utile à l'agréable c'est-à-dire que
moi j'y allais j'avais 17 ans j'avais la
fraîcheur la jeunesse je me prenais pas
la tête rencontrer des tas de gens ça
m'éclater j'étais pas groupé je crois
d'avoir jamais été en tout cas non
c'est peut-être aussi ce qui m'a sauvé
et puis c'est surtout que moi c'est mon
équilibre c'est ma famille depuis l'âge
de 17 ans j'ai toujours rêvé d'être
maman je suis avec trois enfants j'ai
trois enfants donc Joshua Milo et elija
avec le même papa et ça fait 23 ans
[Applaudissements]
alors on vient de découvrir le père de
ses enfants
embrassé avec la langue heureusement
je le précise
normalement non ne dis rien Philippe
quand elle ne dis rien c'est bon il a
déjà eu sa ration là c'est que Séverine
ça a été la première femme à la
télévision en France a montré sa
grossesse c'est la première qu'il a fait
et elle a ouvert la voie à toutes les
autres qui après parce que je me
souviens à l'époque quand on tombe
enceinte on se cachait on faisait pas de
télévision c'était terminé vous êtes
prudent et c'est Sandrine Ferrer c'est
Séverine la première qui est important à
l'antenne et qui a dit moi je continue
je continue mes émissions et tu as
ouvert la voie à toutes les experts à
l'antenne mais c'est vrai et dis-moi
trois enfants alors comment tu gères ça
bah je le gère super bien j'ai trois
générations ben un grand un ado et puis
un tout petit voilà donc je jongle alors
le deuxième le premier a été comédien
mais il a arrêté il est dans la photo
maintenant le deuxième est comédien et
continuer de tourner et maintenant et
très bon ce petit con
mais non mais c'est vrai parce qu'en
fait on a toujours l'impression moi je
suis très objectif et encore plus je
suis plus exigeante avec mes enfants
parce que évidemment je veux le meilleur
et en plus je ne veux pas qu'ils
existent au travers de leur mère j'ai
toujours fait en sorte qu'il ne porte
pas mon nom et qu'on ne le sache pas
donc ça a fuité un moment il fallait
bien que ça c'est pas grave
mais en tout cas ils ont réussi par par
leur talent et par la sueur de leur fond
et ça pour moi c'est très importantes
dans cette émission mais moi je les aime
les casser parce que je les ai souviens
est-ce que tu te souviens que j'avais
présenté l'Eurovision à l'époque pour
Monaco
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était mignon c'était mignon comme toi
chez un moment il y a un porté donc une
très belle chorégraphie d'ailleurs de
Bruno Van Delhi qu'on embrasse et je ne
sais pas ce qui m'a pris je me suis
prise pour Michael Jackson et j'ai fait
I Love You
je pense que tu l'as eu ça parce que du
coup
c'était pénible
[Rires]
tu te rappelles à Monaco c'était en
demi-finale pour l'Eurovision et c'est
une expérience
une des plus belles étoiles chanter
aussi
donc Séverine Ferrer un album épon mais
figure-toi que il y a deux jours j'étais
en studio
qui se passe des choses bon en tout cas
je voudrais parler de cette voix des
femmes on en a beaucoup parlé tout à
l'heure spectacle a reçu le parrainage
du ministère de la Culture bravo on
regarde un extrait
je n'ai rien fait de mal
j'étais confiné avec un lion
me montrer tel que je suis sans faire la
guerre à mon corps et bien c'est déjà
politique je dois encore être enceinte
tu fais chier
vous faites chaleur ballonnement
caractère instable insomnie
il passe une excellente soirée
soyons fiers d'être femme d'être libre
et de parler fort
[Musique]
ce ne sont que des histoires vraies
voilà bravo la voix des femmes de
Séverine Ferrer mise en scène Sabrine
Ferrer des témoignages délivrés
courtiers par des femmes à vous
évidemment et les Alonso
qui ne s'adresse pas de COFA c'est aussi
une merveilleuse déclaration alors les
hommes
23 juin c'est à Rennes
à la rentrée en tournée dans toute la
France cliquez une question pour notre
Séverine fer à vendre son départ
est-ce que c'est volontaires qu'on vous
faites très très rare dans les médias on
vous a pas vu depuis très longtemps et
je voulais savoir pourquoi alors très
simplement parce que faire de la télé
pour faire de la télé ça ne m'intéresse
pas
moi je m'en fiche de la visibilité il en
faut évidemment parce qu'on a besoin de
faire de la promotion etc mais j'essaie
de me faire rare parce que si je n'ai
rien à défendre je n'ai pas forcément
envie de me montrer pour me montrer
voilà c'est plutôt une forme de
protection finalement c'est tout à son
honneur
une dernière question je regarde les
deux
alors moi c'est vrai que je voulais
savoir quand ça s'est arrêté fan de sa
cartonnait on a été tout et on l'a dit
on est que toute fan on était toutes
comme des folles pourquoi ça s'est
arrêté qu'est-ce qui s'est passé bon on
s'entendait plus c'est comme des vieux
cons à un moment quand on s'entend plus
moi j'avais d'autres envies et puis il
ne pouvait pas me les proposer donc on a
préféré se séparer d'accord
souvent pensé dans des projets c'est
même faire et je les ai donc je lui ai
posé les chaînes disent souvent j'aurais
pas faim
tu as pas envie quoi en vrai tu as pas
de temps envie que ça et souvent j'ai
entendu ça de toi alors tu sais on sait
souvent croisé à la fin à la fin alors
j'ai faim je suis une boulimique de
travail j'adore mon métier c'est une
vraie passionné mais je ne suis pas du
genre à aller toquer au Portugal
peut-être
merci ma chérie